what is happening there reject nation we
going to watch today gravity falls
episode five
five all right guys all we ask that you
hit that like button if you haven't
enjoyed our reaction subscribe and click
the notification bell notification for
the next gravity falls is up appreciate
all who have been watching with us uh
thank you to the boys over at prepper
for helping us edit down the highlights
for this and of course full length watch
long as we sync up with the time code
over at our patreon page become a super
reject today by checking out all the
shows we got to offer over there
let's get into it
what's up mr barnes i'm heading out you
do are gonna wash the bathrooms right
yes sir absolutely not
secret ladder to the roof uh i don't
think mr pines would like that uh uh uh
you're freaking me out dude
yes wow
[Music]
jackpot high five
oh homie's got a crush oh
hey it's my friends
wendy
later darts
wow wendy's in action hero yeah where's
the wendy show somebody's in love
yeah right i just think wendy's cool
okay it's not like i lay awake at night
thinking about her
oh no
i get it man trust me i get it most guys
can relate to that
young having a crush on that older girl
for me it was all my aunts
every one of them
every aunt of mine i got a lonely island
song you should check it out
so they can make fun of me yeah yes
exactly no i think it would you would
empathize yeah empathize heavily random
dance party for no reason
go go go go go go go go go
i've done that
i uh don't really dance yeah you do mom
used to dress him up in a lamb costume
and make him do the lamby dance whoa is
there like little ears and a tail uh uh
zipper would prance around oh of course
you've got it on hand
you love her love love love love love oh
hey what's that huh
[Music]
oh yeah
gross hey guys are my pals from work
mabel and dipper i chewed my gum so it
looks like a brain what she's not much
for first impressions unlike this guy
oh god oh boy who's got two thumbs and
made it awkward robbie you can probably
figure him out
yeah i'm the guy who spray-painted the
water tower oh you mean the big muffins
um it's a giant explosion
like a muffin
oh no dipper guys i got big plans for
tonight huh yeah all right let's get out
of here
[Music]
sorry kid all right shotgun all right
tj miller that's tj miller completely
unproblematic placement
you encounter like a slasher yeah it's
like the texas chainsaw massacre i can't
find the remote and i refuse to stand up
stay tuned for the friday night movie
the duchess of prove starring sterling
stumble burgess has the duchess and
grabbed at saint rumper frable as they
wrassle the cocksuite chocolate chiron
kids
[Laughter]
there it is fellas the condemned dust to
dawn
neato
why did they shut it down it's like a
health code violation or try murder some
folks died in there the place has been
haunted ever since oh good yeah let's do
it
are you guys serious yeah we're all
gonna die
chill out man it's not as bad as it
looks
come on dipper
okay okay just just just uh gotta get a
foothold dude your sister did it
this place is amazing i think it's it's
stuck let me take a crack at it oh yeah
i can't get in but i'm sure a junior
here is gonna break it down like
hercules come on leave him alone he's
just a little kid
oh
time to put some hair on that chest
young man
whoa kiss what are you doing
no golly
punch that metal thing test hosta road
take it easy who wants to bet he doesn't
make it
[Music]
awesome
good call inviting this little maniac
your new name is dr funtime
i wish dr fudd time guys check it out
you think they still work
[Music]
nice
unbelievable
jackpot so what are we gonna do now
anything we want guess some of those
donuts
yeah
oh my god guys that's probably so gross
[Music]
oh my gosh
smile dip i thought this stuff was
banned in america das flavor
[Laughter]
and your sister seems to be going nuts
for that smile dip uh
maybe i've had too much
what do you think
oh my holy there is no d in there
you pause
of course you little angel
[Music]
live your best life mabel
you're surprisingly mature for your age
yes yes i am
that's when i developed my eating
problem
with the dead bodies being here
[Music]
hurry up go go go go wow he's really
terrible at this
yeah yeah that's that's great
oh my goodness nice i may be a duchess
but i'm also a woman yes yes
in your face elizabeth it's just like my
life
let your feels out
mabel i need your advice we're hanging
out in a haunted convenience store i
can't get a hold of grunkle stan and if
i try to say anything about it to any of
these guys they'll just think i'm a
scared little kid or something
the future is in the past
the future is the best
[Music]
trapped in store with insane
nine-year-old i'm not a nine-year-old
i'm 13. technically a teen
holy
here we go
what
status update
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are we supposed to do i don't know
man i don't know let's just go already
thompson wait
oh he's got the high score
oh it's off
no
huh what time to shake what your mama
gave you
oh my god
whatever is doing this has to have some
kind of reason maybe if we could just
figure out what it is then they'll let
us out of here they'll let us out of
here yeah that makes a lot of sense
maybe he's got a point yeah right i'm
sure the ghost just wants to talk about
his feelings
it's got unfinished business man
i'm bunkers for eating you alive
can you escape
oh no no
no no no i'm a hot dog oh no oh it's
gonna burn alive
[Music]
now's your time to shine dips quick in
there
[Music]
normal teenage things of course stay
here until i get back
dude what are you doing
this is a job for a kid
hey
ghost hodo
i've got something to tell you
i'm not a teenager
you were lying about your age when we
were alive teenagers were a scourge on
our store always sassafras and customers
with their boomy boxes and disrespectful
short pants
they did the up and band them but they
retaliated with this newfangled rap
music
the lyrics they were so hateful
homework's whack and so are rules
we were stricken down with double heart
attacks
[Music]
that's why we hate teenagers so much
don't we honey
but they're my friends isn't there
anything i can do to help them there is
one thing
do you know any funny little dances uh
oh no
well
who wants a lambie lambie lambie i do i
do so go up and greet your mammy mammy
oh god
yes
oh they're perverts
some sick fetish
that was some fine girly dancing boy
your friends are free
well i don't think you have to worry
about us coming back so
[Music]
that's cool the ghosts appeared and
dipper had to
[Music]
uh
and um dipper just grabbed a bat and
started beating ghosts down left and
right and then
[Laughter]
dr fun times
ah
they're definitely in love now
ah the wedding i've waited so long for
this oh look at her in that dress
waited two whole hours for this
uh
couldn't find the remote
well done
well done
yes
nah
that was my favorite one we've watched
so far
buy it buy a long
but
buy a
lot the other one sucked compared to
this
yes
so
true
suck it episodes one through four
episode five is here to claim the throne
yeah that was great that that did all
the ingredients that i've liked the from
the episodes that i've really liked a
lot that did everything that um
i've wanted the ones that i didn't feel
met its potential to do and i thought
this one really they went all out with
doing it you know like you're dealing
with dipper and the social anxiety of
having to be around teenagers when
you're not quite a teenager yet i really
can't i as a guy i i don't know what
it's like to be a girl dealing with that
i feel like
girls are usually just more accepting of
each other even though there's some
[ __ ] out there
but i think
it's discrimination based on age perhaps
yeah but i do know what it's like to be
that like 12 year old boy hanging out
with like 16 year olds it can be really
awkward and and very uncomfortable and
especially and so deal you're like
that's like your primal
identifiable vibe that you have with
dipper
and then having like a crush on on the
older girl you know
there's many situations that people can
land themselves into whether it's an
extracurricular activity or like if
they're taking classes somewhere outside
for some other sport activity outside of
school could be in school there's a wide
variety of scenarios where that's
happened with a lot of people that's
happened with me when i was like a
little boy too so you have these very
identifiable themes
of what it's like and then when they go
to the horror side they really go all
out like i thought the horror was really
well done it was actually this is the
first one where i was
actually sitting here going it was kind
of scary it was kind of creepy yeah and
yeah and it didn't seem to like to hold
back too much for what disney xd is
and i was pleasantly surprised by that
of okay they're really doing like a
horror thing right now instead of just
making fun of the horror yeah and so i
really appreciated it and it had i
thought it had like a really good wrap
around to it all had a lot of heart so
and all honestly i thought that was a
really well told episode yeah absolutely
it was well paced and well proportioned
and yeah it had a nice gradual build you
know keeping the the fun and the jokes
going along the way but yeah it didn't i
feel like in some of the past the
previous couple episodes we've sort of
talked about you know this sort of
proportions maybe feeling
a little off or like they could get to
the point quicker and yeah this one got
right to it and yeah i love the way that
they realize like everyone dissipating
and then going into the one goes into
the tv the other one goes in the game
and it's like even though they're not
meeting the most horrific fates at the
same time you're like yeah this does
look kind of hellish and unpleasant
you've got like these arrows raining
down and sticking out of your back a guy
turning into a hot dog yeah i turned to
a hot guy i'm like yeah this guy's gonna
roast stuff yeah and uh and even the
like disembodied brain and eyes like
yeah it's all the right amount of
heightened to where a not quite teenager
could still watch it and it's not too
much but at the same time it's clearly
informed by and going to satisfy a lot
of people who know what movies they're
riffing on and whatnot and and i'm
always a sucker
for uh
you know an innocuous
drug trip in a kid's show like i loved
uh mabel's weird uh fun dip experience
yeah oftentimes i feel like when mabel
works best so far
and maybe this will change over the
course of the series but i feel like
mabel actually works best when she's
more of knowing how to position her as a
supporting wild card yeah or like
dipper's wore the lead and then when you
make her because she's so wacky and
eccentric and such an aloof kind of
character that when you have her
gradually get weirder in an episode or
go crazier so that's when she's at her
funniest
and when it's not like you're the she's
not the center of attention on the plot
yeah when your expectation that she's
going to say something random isn't kind
of the whole thing yeah you know it's
like how she's going to play off of the
situation rather than just you know like
resting mabel you can count on to say
something wacky and there will be a joke
here but whereas yeah
the support in a situation like that you
can bring the character comedy i feel
like a little better out of her well
they do like a good kind of sketch with
her yeah
like i like when she picks up the the
the the dip
she dips it in
yeah that's a really great game yeah
yeah classic yeah a lot of times they do
set you up for what to expect and then
they kind of just do the opposite yeah
it's a good subversion and uh that's a
big part of like their comedy in this
show is like really set you up for what
you would kind of expect to punch so
whatever they do what you would expect
i'm not a big fan of it
like grunkle stan watching the like
there were some funny lines in there for
sure but it was so like yeah that's like
a predictable yeah oh yeah i don't want
to watch this but i'm so wondering i'm
crying because i'm gonna get into it
yeah yeah yeah so like that that bit
is like one of the bits that i wasn't
like a big fan of just because i like i
really like when this show does the
here's what we're setting you up for
then now here's the diversion you know
and i think this show does a really good
job a lot of times if even for me going
i didn't see that joke coming at all
yeah you know totally or when they do go
to the extreme sometimes i i often have
in like
i feel like three out of the five
episodes i do find myself going i wish
they went it's a little bit more with
the actual monster of the week that
they're dealing with or the horror and
here i thought they'd do just enough
like they built it up nicely you could
always feel that there was a threat
coming
that's what i think wyatt complimented
so well because they're like okay is
this going to be the episode where they
play on like small town high school or
kids having a rebellious night and which
it is you know a rebellious night and
then they're being attacked i thought
it'd be like a singular villain that's
going to go after them
instead of this more sci-fi horror that
evolves into some like body horror stuff
and i thought when they did that it they
they utilized the creativity they really
committed and let you live in that
moment they even had the you know
flashback explaining the origin of why
these ghosts do what they do you know
oh the hip-hop yeah yeah yeah one that's
a great thing too because that plays
you know on a stereotype of like uh you
kids and your music but you know that
like that's an instance of they just go
so silly and stupid with the rap lyrics
that it comes back around to being
pretty funny yeah and just the fact that
yeah they they had heart attacks over
this and are now like terrorizing
teenagers because of it and all it takes
is well i'm 12.
yeah like yeah there's there's a whimsy
there that is quite charming and and
yeah i think i love wendy a lot too yeah
yeah she's really grown as a character
in five episodes she's gone from like
one word lines to now being an actual
character she went from like how aubry
plaza is always cast as in the early
days yeah as dry sarcastic
indie girl yeah or or not not even her
that's even like uh i would say more of
um god what the hell is that woman's
name
deschanel zoe dishnow so yeah there yeah
zoey national more like a zoe de chanel
to now
a character
justifying that linda carlini voiceover
that's on the carlini okay yeah cause
that's the thing is i caught her name i
think in the first episodes credits and
then the second and i was like that's
weird it seems like she literally does
show up to say one or two words and
that's it yeah yeah to see that
expansion makes a lot more sense uh yeah
this was a fun house one i i like this
one a lot and i was very much
i found it relatable
like that when i say like having that
little bit of
my if you stick around for the review
part of these episodes
um whatever i'm talking about having
like that little bit of extra nuance
that makes all the horror and the comedy
shine that much more
this episode really did that i thought
very well um as bad on par with the
pilot
so yeah or even stronger than the pilot
actually this is well character oriented
yeah cause it's all stemmed from the mo
like every single time dipper
you know went the extra step it was
because he either felt pressure or was
trying to prove a point
you know it wasn't just being like
stupid you know yeah just like silliness
for the sake of because it's a cartoon
yeah yeah i was always trying to like
match with the the
the teenagers who can be intimidating to
him yeah there's always that tension
throughout
yeah i think the way they make fun of
like bros of that age is really funny oh
those dudes high-fiving like over
everything yeah yeah
yeah
to the point where they're i love that
last bit where it's like they didn't
even do anything and they're high-fiving
each other yeah accomplishments this is
a this is a really fun episode i i enjoy
this one a lot
sincerely
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell hit
that like button we'll catch you all
soon thanks for being
[Music]